the first question I asked was well
why's she wicked I mean no one is purely
evil everyone's got a motivation and
because it's a story about a girl who
was quintessentially essentially
beautiful and kind and good and has to
find the courage within her to sort of
overcome her circumstances a stepmother
sits in relief of that and that she is
the sort of the perversion of what
happens to someone when when the good is
perverted it often turns wicked so I was
interested in exploring what makes
someone ugly or wicked and even though a
lot of the initial getting to know you
with Lady Tremaine who I play and the
stepdaughters is done sort of through
montage and and voiceover through those
little tiny vignettes you hopefully
begin to get a glimpse of the fact that
this is a woman who's tried to start her
life again and becomes intensely jealous
of the the deep affection that her new
husband has for his daughter who is
Cinderella and once he dies and the
financial pressures and the the the
panic and that jealousy grow and that
that is what makes her wicked is that
she is she's not young and not as
beautiful and not as kind and not as
good as Cinderella and that there in a
way Cinderella becomes her nemesis and
you know to horrible ends I'm a great
lover of fairy tales I grew up on them
and you know I read them constantly to
my children even though I've got three
boys you know I've still read them
Cinderella and Beauty and the Beast and
Snow White I think I love fairy tales
and Cinderella in particular because
they deal with really complex issues
that face children but and but often in
quite confronting ways and so many
stories that children get told now I
think are always trying to avoid sadness
avoid conflict make them feel like
they're here
it doesn't necessarily you know they can
overcome anything in the world is a
perfect place and the great thing about
you know those wonderful old timeless
fairy tales like Cinderella is that they
say that the world can be a nasty place
out there and you need a lot of courage
and you need a lot of resilience and and
you will fall down before you stand up
and I think they're all the things that
happened to Cinderella and there's so
many I have three boys so many films out
there at the moment that have male
superheroes at the fore and this is
really a story where kindness is a
superpower and that's something that Ken
talked about really early on and I found
that really really exciting and it's a
female centric story and and I was
really excited to be part of the telling
of that the first time I walked onto the
set even before it was lit I was
gobsmacked I'm now had to pick my jaw
off of the floor and then to see what
sandy did with the costumes it was
really like an MGM Technicolor moment it
was I felt like I was transported back
in term in terms of cinema and so that
was a wonderful story book world to
enter it's fantastic it's really you
know it was so much fun to be had and
also because you're collaborating with
people like Ken and like Dante Ferretti
and Sandy Powell and more across and Kay
Georgio who did hair and makeup so
you're all collaborating on creating
these extraordinary visuals and when
you're given a silhouette like that this
is say that sandy created and we tried
to sort of make it a hybrid almost like
it was a period film told in the 1940s
like a 1940's version of period then you
have to rise to that silhouette so it
gives you so much and then what I think
what Ken was able to or interested in
finding was that storybook theatricality
but with you know the core of truth he
didn't want he didn't want to go for the
high camp which you can absolutely do in
a fairy tale
he wanted to make it all so quiet and
true so it was a balancing act trying to
find those two things but also inhabit
the silhouette it was great fun and as
soon as Lily came on she's like a breath
of fresh air she's totally unaffected
she's like a glass of water she allows
you in but gives so much back and there
was you could just there's a generosity
of spirit to her as a performer which i
think is really rare and an incredible
discipline and focus and depth but she's
also such a blyve spirit so I think
she's absolutely perfect for the role
she glows when the prince and cinderella
began to dance when when Richard and
Lily took the floor it was really hot
because obviously my character has to be
suspicious and judgmental and profoundly
jealous it made me just want to weep
because he were these two young people
who had worked so hard and so long and
his dance and I know what it's like to
dance and of course that Lily was so I
mean she literally was carrying around a
whole merry-go-round with her but there
was so graceful and so true and and they
kept the focus on one another it was I
mean I don't think there was a dry eye
in the room it was really really moving
that when he goes he Billy Elliot
onstage those boys can absolutely do
what the character says they can do that
and and so you were transported by the
actors ability and so those two young
people moving around with this really
complicated beautiful dance that that
that Rob Ashford had had choreographed
it was profoundly moving and you know it
was one of those moments where you
thought this is actually absolutely sort
of superseded my expectations I it's a
complete experience and I've really
fully realized that when we filmed the
ball sequence you just don't see that
you don't see those grand romantic
moments where you say yes there was a
moment with all the extras is a couple
of beautiful really difficult lifts
that that Richard and Lily did in the
dance and everyone just erupted into
applause naturally when when it happened
because it was so beautiful and I think
this you're really genuinely rooting for
her and you don't a couple of the times
when we were I mean obviously we all
know the story but we all know the story
of Hamlet but we go and see Hamlet over
and over again because you want to think
maybe this time he will kill Claudius
and the best possible production of
Hamlet makes you think that and there
were several scenes that was shot where
I thought maybe she's not going to maybe
you know she's not going to find the
courage to to bite back at this at this
woman or and and so I was really
surprised by a lot of the scenes and I
think because it's so true and therefore
truly funny and truly tragic I think
people are going to feel that they're
being told the story for the first time
ken has great comic timing and he's
incredibly great with with directorial
details they're coming in and finessing
something and he's also very open being
an actor himself and such a great actor
he's he's very good at at using the
rehearsal time in the morning because
often times you know you'll come on and
and every actor has a different process
in a different way of getting into the
role and so he's able to incorporate
everyone's process and make it feel like
it's a collective effort and it's a
behemoth
you know the legacy of you know this
being a Disney classic in cartoon form
and a classic in a fairy tale sense
there's such an expectation and he was
able to find this way where the tone of
the film is as a as at once sweet and
delightful but also sinister and he was
able to get the harness the domestic
moments between people and characters
and also the really grand moments I
think he knows he's got an inherent and
wonderful sense of rhythm as
you